here's what would happen if you drank  from lake natron  well right away you'd burn your lips and  tongue lake natron is flooded with  underground water that can be as hot as  60 degrees celsius  this corrosive water would continue  burning your mouth esophagus stomach  your insides would feel like they were  on fire and if you drank enough of this  water the alkaline liquid would burn a  hole in your stomach your abdominal pain  would be crippling and while your  stomach is burning the cyanobacteria  contaminating the water would make you  feel nauseous and would give you  diarrhea  lake natron has high levels of sodium  and chlorine together they combine to  create sodium chloride or salt  continuing to drink the salty lake  nature on water would make you pee more  water than you drank  you'd become thirstier and more  dehydrated and  eventually you'd die  so  stick with toxin-free water because